based on the examples in the last video
let's see if we can come up with some
rules of thumb for figuring out how many
significant figures or how many
significant digits there are in a number
or a measurement so the first thing that
is pretty obvious is that any non-zero
digit and any of the zero digits in
between are significant clearly the 7
and the 5 here is significant and the 0
is in between them it's also going to be
significant so let's write this over
here so any nonzero digits non-zero
digits and zeros in between zeros in
between are going to be significant are
going to be significant that's pretty
straightforward now the the zeros that
are not in between nonzero digits these
become a little bit more confusing so
let's let's just make sure we can rule
out some of them so you can always leat
rule out when you're thinking about
significant figures the leading zeros
I'm going to talk about leading zeros
I'm talking about the zeros that come
before your non-zero digit so these are
leading zeros here these are leading
zeros
there's no leading zeros here no leading
zeros in this one this one and this one
but in any situation the leading zeros
are not significant so leading zeros not
significant all right over here
leading leading zeros not not
significant and so the last question all
you have left I mean you only have
nonzero digits and zeros in between you
could have some leading zeros which
we've already said are not significant
and so the only thing left that you have
to figure out is what do you do with the
trailing zeros the zeros the zeros
behind the last non-zero or to the right
of the last non-zero digit so these
trailing zeros here there's a trailing
there's actually two trailing zeros over
here and then there's three trailing
zeros over here so let me make a little
so trailing zeros trailing trailing
zeros what do we do with them so the
easy way to think about it is if you
have a decimal if there's a decimal
anywhere in your number count them if
you have a decimal count them
them count them as significant they are
significant than they are count them as
significant if there's no decimal no
decimal anywhere in the number then it's
kind of ambiguous you kind of not sure
and this is a situation so the so
clearly over here there's a decimal in
the number so you count the trailing
zeros these are adding to the precision
over here there's a decimal so you count
the trailing zero there's a decimal here
so you count the trailing zeros there
are no trailing zeros here and over here
well the way I later put a decimal here
here you would count it so if you have
the decimal there you would count all
five if you didn't have the decimal if
you just had 37,000 like that it's
ambiguous and if someone doesn't give
you more information your best
assumption is probably that they just
measured to the nearest thousand that
they didn't measure exactly to the one
and just happen to get exactly on 37,000
so if there's no decimal let me write it
this way there's it's ambiguous
ambiguous which means that you're you
really don't you're not sure what it
means it's not clear what it means and
you're probably safer assuming to not
count it so not not count not count the
trailing the trailing zeroes if someone
really does measure if you were to
really measure something to the exact
one then you should put a decimal at the
end like that and there is a notation
for specifying let's say you have you do
measure and let me do a different number
let's say you do measure 55 56,000 and
there is a notation for specifying that
six definitely is the last significant
digit and sometimes you'll see a bar put
over the six sometimes you'll see a bar
put under the six and that could be
useful because maybe maybe your last
significant digit is this zero over here
maybe you were able to measure to the
hundreds with a reasonable level of
precision and so then you would have to
you would write something like five hunt
or there's to still write 56,000 but
then you would put the bar above that
zero or the bar below that zero to say
that if that was the
significant digit so if you saw
something like this you would say three
three significant digits this isn't used
so frequently a better way to show that
you've measured two three significant
digits would be to write it in
scientific notation and there's a whole
video on that but to write this in
scientific notation you could write this
as five point six zero times 10 to the
fourth power right because you have
you'll have to if you multiply this
times 10 to the fourth you would move
this decimal over four spaces and get us
to 56,000 so five point six zero times
ten to the fourth and if this confuses
you watch the video on scientific
notation will hopefully clarify things a
little bit but when you write a number
in scientific notation it makes it very
clear about your precision and how many
significant digits you're dealing with
so instead of doing this notation that's
a little bit outdated I haven't seen it
used much with these bars below or above
the high significant digit you instead
you can represent it with a decimal in
in scientific notation there it's very
clear it's very clear that you have
three significant digits so hopefully
that helps you out in the next couple of
videos we'll explore a little bit more
why significant digits are important
especially when you do calculations with
multiple measurements